Trey Young's got it Trey young breaking
the paint floater in the lane he's tied
the game that was too easy no timeouts
either way seven seconds Draymond at
five
play for the lead long Looney tip no
Looney
and your joy is full
come on Looney on a 20 rebound night his
second follow gives the Warriors the win
give that man the game ball
that's just pure effort who wants it
more
Looney is unbelievable
14 points 21 boards five assists
they went to replay to confirm it you
could see it live it was good but
if I win the Warriors have won five in a
row in the home stand they're 17-2 in
the building Looney playing volleyball
and he sent it home we are not going to
a third overtime
this is over you could give away a
couple game balls tonight clay
definitely deserves one
and Clay got the last shot there small
Defender trying to box out Looney that's
not gonna work
got a couple opportunities there Philly
Thompson out of 54.9
the Warriors love it
and come on Looney
who might be the most popular Warrior
amongst his teammates who does all the
hard work
he gets the Buster Peterson double
OT oh that's a devastating loss Clay
Thompson who had 54.
clay you got anything left for the
interview or did you use it all out on
the floor my Tank's on eBay my tank is
on e thank God for Kevon Looney man oh
my goodness
strikes again I want I want to take you
back to a conversation we had on the
team bus this is true leaving Brooklyn
as down as the team was of that road
trip and you said we're coming home and
there are better days ahead you spoke it
into existence it's a five-game winning
streak one flip the switch
I mean I think it was your inspiration
inspirational talk Bobby the one who
told you everything's gonna be all right
like Bob Marley so I appreciate you for
seeing this happen kind of like a
you got some telepiving skills over
there buddy but uh that was a great
conversation we had and that was a rough
road trip so it's fun to get those wins
back in front of our fans and talk about
the work you guys have done defensively
down the stretch to go 5-0 on this home
stand draymond's been unbelievable
you've been great kavan Looney just
holding down the paint what is it taking
on that end to Come Away with these wins
some of these improbable wins oh man got
the effort from everybody I mean through
a PBJ did tonight man barely played the
whole season he comes again and gets
eight great points
finger roll he really
emphasized that jelly in his name so
just all around strength and numbers
effort so proud of everybody we've grown
so much in these last two weeks now clay
your first 50 ball since coming back
from the surgeries
54. uh I I thought you weren't ever
going to become a great player again
that's what a bunch of Knuckleheads were
saying uh they could take that 54 and
stick it yes they can with more to come
Bob I'm dead y'all I appreciate y'all
see you later all right thanks for
stopping Klay Thompson